the British Empire was once the largest
in the world the city of London
unrivaled for economic prowess and we
exported more than anyone else but all
this has been in steady decline since
the loss of the empire seven decades ago
our tiny country has tried to hold on to
being a global power we're still
respected around the world with a seat
at the top table including on the UN
Security Council but we could be so much
more earlier this month
fifty three countries came together for
Commonwealth today I wonder how many of
you even knew about the celebrations
taking place these countries combined
make up less than 10% of Britain's trade
but the future potential is enormous
previously at the heart of this
fantastic institution it is sad the UK
is increasingly marginalized as brexit
steals the limelight the world is
looking at us and saying what is
happening to this great country why are
you doing this to yourselves this is all
so unnecessary Britain is a country the
world is always respected let's not risk
losing our position even further current
do you know what the director of the
Institute for Commonwealth Studies calls
the Commonwealth an irrelevant
institution wallowing in imperial
amnesia that's the director of the
Institute for Commonwealth studies not
my quote although I think it's quite
accurate I agree with your sentiment
which is I think every nation wants to
increase its standing in the world and
be as relevant as possible and it's been
very painful for Britain and many
British people that Britain has been in
long-term structural decline and I
completely understand why there is this
sentiment of wanting to get back that
position but the reality is we do no
longer have an empire and the
Commonwealth is not a substitute for the
Empire and I worry that people see it
that way and in some ways that has
served Britain in that way look at look
at what the Commonwealth does for
Britain it promotes liberalised
extractor friendly regimes around the
world
it creates the system of corporate tax
havens in other Commonwealth countries
that allow British companies not to pay
tax of any other Commonwealth countries
you know
portray as a kind of membership friendly
nations all equal in which case why is
it that only one African or Asian
Commonwealth nation is benefiting from
the new post brexit immigration rules
why have we been deporting Commonwealth
citizens to countries when they're
British when their countries don't want
them there are so many things about the
Commonwealth that revealed that it's not
this friendly happy Club that we like to
see it as and the reason we reinforce
that narrative is just to make ourselves
feel better about the fact that the
world has irreparable and I think been
officially changed we don't we know us
talking about inferior reality that's
all in the past if you look at the
Commonwealth Charter look at the
Commonwealth Charter at the essence we
just have a look at it the essence of it
is it's a force for good it is it is a
voluntary organisation not one of these
53 countries is forced to join it people
and there's a there's a queue of
countries who want to join it and so
what the point I'm making here is
Britain had a great Empire was the
biggest Empire in the modern world but
today it is still considered a global
power was still at the top table of the
world including g7 g8 you the UN
Security Council permanent seat but now
we're not going to be at the table at
Europe so our standing in the world is
diminishing and I think it's a huge
mistake something like common law
there's enormous potential what I don't
like is the way the breaks a tear say if
we leave Europe we can do more with the
Commonwealth the common rule makes up
less than 10% of written straight
including India Canada New Zealand
Australia I'm saying we're done through
thee I'm not against a club in which
Britain is a member but I don't think
you get the benefit of saying that this
is a friendly ties with equal countries
if you don't treat them as such which we
don't and in terms of countries
voluntarily joining yes they do you know
32 of the countries in the Commonwealth
have a fewer than 1.5 million people
these are small countries that were
brought into the global economy okay
so I'm going to stick up for the
Commonwealth 53 countries it has a GDP
of ten point four trillion dollars by
2020 that's predicted to be thirteen
trillion dollars it has a diversity of
markets said the EU
only dream about in the past five or six
years it has increased its GDP by five
percent whereas the EU has increased it
over 20 years by nought point three
percent which is nothing but also what I
want to talk to you about the EU being
part of the EU is it a strategy to be an
independent player on the world stage
it's a substitute for a strategy it's
letting others define our goals and aims
we want on the world stage long before
we joined the EU we will be will be on
it long after we're still the fifth
largest economy in the world our
economies are way more prosperous than
Germany and currently Italy and France
so you're running things that would
simply aren't true that's your
perception of what's happening the
reality is different well the reality is
Kerala in 1922 we controlled in the
British Empire I snoozed the Royal we
458 million people the Sun never set on
the British Empire but Carol newsflash
since then it has been the job of the
common of the Foreign and Commonwealth
Office where I once worked we were told
that we were trying to punch above our
weight but basically the job was the
orderly management of our decline and
that is the case and now with my Fortran
where's a direct flight which is
probably a national humiliation for this
country to the world what can take us
I'm afraid at their estimation not ours
let's just reflect back on what Canon
was talking about which is an
opportunity to use the Commonwealth that
was at the heart of what he said and
you've quoted a gentleman whose name
I've forgotten from the Commonwealth
Institute of Education what do you
suppose 2.2 billion people call the
Commonwealth they call it home that's
how many people are encompassed by the
Commonwealth if that isn't an
extraordinary opportunity I don't know
what is what is ii had won that second
and what i find extraordinary is when
you land at Heathrow or you land at
Gatwick there are people from India
there are people in Australia there are
people in Canada a relative of mine who
have been in the trenches with these
with the Britons from World War 1
through world war 2 and they are held
back meanwhile the jerk I have nothing
against the Germans I have nothing
against Italians look at my last name
they file through that I find truly
extraordinary from the Commonwealth
Oh served and the first and second world
wars volunteers many gave their lives so
we owe a lot to the countries of the
Commonwealth but I think here the
similarity with the EU look at the
difference the big thing Commonwealth
does not have is it doesn't have a
single market or a customs union or a
free trading bloc it just doesn't have
it
the biggest benefit economically of the
European Union is that five hundred
million strong biggest trading bloc in
the world which we are completely going
to be giving up now and we're losing and
we're losing our standing in the world
by the way already we've lost in London
has lost its number one position as the
number one financial centre in the world
thanks to brakes it because we've got a
group of MP squabbling that's why it
once that is settled things will settle
down and you know Britain is supposed to
usher in a new age it's supposed to do
if we could get all of it I have a
question I noticed a lot I know a lot of
people of African and Asian heritage who
voted for brexit because of what you're
saying Nick this idea that of course you
know people like my family from Ghana do
you have these historic ties in Britain
and they have been behind Europeans and
having access to Britain and I noticed
recently that there was a change in
immigration figures that immigration
within the EU has declined quite
dramatically since brexit immigration
from outside that use specially from
wealth has increased
I was listening for brexit ears cheering
that statistic welcoming the increase in
Commonwealth I didn't because they don't
want more immigration for some alone I
mean so here you say we don't need you
we have the Commonwealth well where is
that huge embrace that have people from
the Commonwealth freely move here do you
just watch people get tired of efforts
it's it's you people like you
insinuating that the reason people want
brixon is because the thick racist
people change in three years in this
point you brought up an important point
big change three years ago immigration
was right up there as a concern in this
country among the brave publics
now in three three years later it's
number its lowest in 16 years as
people's concern is no longer a top
concern at all
and that is because they assume that
with brexit there will be curbs we will
get control back of our boarders job
done you know it now let's move another
brave thing the increase in immigration
really you that was my question about it
I hope today you say anything celebrates
but then again you're trying to admit
that I don't want to get into these any
point of order